[Music]
Ghana is mourning one of its Sons
outside the state house in the capital
Accra is the coffin of the late football
star Christian achoo hundreds gathered
family members former players managers
and a legion of fans including orphans
that at you helped all here to pay
tribute to the former Newcastle Winger
who died in last month's earthquake in
Turkey
[Music]
but then we heard the bad news that he
had died
while he played for turkey as hataya
sport atsu spent most of his career in
the English Premier League playing for
Chelsea Newcastle and Everton he also
made 65 appearances for Ghana's national
team helping the black stars reach the
final of the 2015 Africa Cup of Nations
in Equatorial Guinea he was awarded goal
and player of the tournament
yeah today is a very sad day to us we
it's not even the footballers per se or
Sports per se everybody in Ghana is sad
today you know such a talent is going
too early in my opinion
in Ghana's tradition funerals are
ascend-off to the other world
a moment of both grief and celebration
atsu used his talent to spread joy to
millions of people in Ghana and beyond
for many this isn't just a funeral
it's a last goodbye to a football star
Nicholas Hawk Al Jazeera